we believe he reached the crowded  beachfront at around this point with  witnesses saying he drove its speed for  a mile along the promenade des anglais  some of the first images of casualties  to emerge were taken outside Apartments  around this location opposite Florida  Beach  the injured were treated at triage  centers and makeshift hospitals which  was set up on the beach on the street  and in hotels including the hotel  Negresco footage shows the truck  accelerating along a promenade outside  the Westminster Hotel photo showed  dozens of bodies covered with blankets  around this location truck finally came  to a stop outside the Hyatt Regency  Hotel